evening i will now do a presentation on
the center of mass and the center of
mass i hope hopefully is is something
that will be a little bit intuitive to
you and uh actually has some very neat
applications
so in in very simple terms
the center of mass is a point let me
draw an object let's say
let's say that this
this is my object let's see it's a ruler
and so this ruler it exists so it has
some mass and my question to you is what
is the center of mass and you say so
well in order to figure out the center
of mass you have to tell me what the
center of mass is and what i tell you is
the center of mass is a point and it
actually doesn't have to even be a point
in the object it and i'll do an example
soon where it won't be but it's a point
and at that point for dealing with this
object as a whole or the mass of the
object of the hole we can pretend that
the entire mass exists at that point and
what do i mean by saying that well let's
say that the center of mass is
here
and i'll tell you why i picked this
point because that is pretty close to
where the center of mass will be
if the center of mass is there and let's
say the mass
of this entire ruler is i don't know 10
kilograms
this ruler if a force
if a force is applied at the center of
mass
let's say 10 newtons
right so the mass of the skill of the
whole ruler
is 10 kilograms
10 kilograms if a force is applied at
the center of mass this ruler will
accelerate
the same exact way as would a point mass
let's say that we had just had a little
dot but that little dot had the same
mass
10 kilograms
and we were to push on that dot with 10
newtons
in either case in the case of the ruler
we would accelerate upwards at what
force divided by mass so we'd accelerate
upwards at one meter per second squared
and in the in this case of this point
mass we would accelerate that point when
i say point mass i'm just saying like
something really really small but it has
a mass of 10 kilograms so it's much
smaller but has the same masses ruler
this would also accelerate upwards
with a magnitude of 1 meters per second
squared
so why is this useful to us
well sometimes we have some really crazy
objects and we want to figure out
exactly what it does and if we know its
center of mass first we can know how
that object will behave without having
to worry about the shape of the object
and i'll give you a really easy way of
of realizing where the center of mass is
if the object
has a unifor uniform distribution when i
say that it means you know the let's say
i mean for simple purposes if it's made
out of the same thing and that thing
that it's made out of its density uh
doesn't really change throughout the
object the center of mass is re is will
be the object's geogra
it's a geometric center so in this case
this is all you know ruler is almost a
one dimensional object we just went
halfway the distance from here to here
and the distance from here to here same
as the center of mass if we had a two
dimensional object let's say we had like
this triangle
and we wanted to figure out its center
of mass
it will be the center in two dimensions
so it will be something like that
now if i had another situation let's say
i had a
oh i don't know
let's say that i have this
square
um that's
thick enough for you to see let me draw
a little thicker
let's say i have the square
but let's say that
half of this square is made from
let me see half of the square let's say
this half of the square is made from
lead
let's say this half is made from lead
and let's say the other half of the
square i don't know it's made from
something lighter than lead it's made of
styrofoam that is lighter than lead
so in this situation the center of mass
isn't going to be the geographic center
i don't know how much denser lead is in
styrofoam but the center of mass is
going to be someplace closer
to the right because this this object
does not have a uniform density and it
will actually depend on how much denser
the lead is than the styrofoam which i
don't know
but hopefully that gives you a little
intuition of of what the center of mass
is
and now i'll tell you
something a little more interesting
every problem we have done so far i
actually made or we actually made the
simplifying assumption that the force
acts on the center of mass
so if i have an object
let's say the object
that looks like a horse
that's let's say that object
if this is the object's center of mass i
don't know where the horse's center of
mass normally is but let's say a horse's
center of mass is here
if i apply a force directly on that
center of mass
if i apply a force directly at that
then the object will move in the
direction of that force
with the appropriate acceleration i mean
we could divide the force by the by the
mass of the entire horse and we would
figure out the acceleration
in that direction
but now i will throw in a twist and
actually every problem we did every all
of these newton's laws problems we
assumed that the force acted at the
center of mass
but something more interesting happens
if the force acts away from the center
of mass
so let me see
actually let me actually take that ruler
example i don't know why i even drew the
horse
if i have this ruler again
and
this is the center of mass as we said
any any force that we act on the center
of mass the whole object will move in
the direction of the force
it'll be shifted by the force
essentially but now this is what's
interesting if that's the center of mass
and if i were to apply a force someplace
else away from the center of mass
let's say i apply a force here
i want you to think about for a second
what will probably happen to the object
well it turns out that the object will
rotate and so you know think about we're
on the space shuttle or we're in deep
space or something and if i have a ruler
and if i just push at one end of the
ruler what's going to happen am i just
going to push the whole ruler or is the
whole ruler going to rotate and
hopefully your intuition is correct the
whole ruler will rotate around the
center of mass
in general if if you
were to throw us
a monkey wrench at someone and i don't
recommend that you do but if you did and
and while the monkey wrench is spinning
in the air it's spinning around its
center of mass some same for a knife
that you know if you're a knife catcher
that's that's something you should think
about that the object when it's in a
when it's when it's free when it's not
fixed to any point it rotates around its
center of mass and that that's that's
very interesting so you can actually
throw random objects
and that point at which it rotates
around that's the object center of mass
that's that's a experiment that that you
should do in an open field around no one
else
now
with all of this and and i'll actually
in the next video tell you what this is
when you have a force that causes
rotational motion as opposed to a
shifting motion that's torque but we'll
do that in the next video but now i'll
show you just a cool example of how a
centered the center of mass is relevant
in everyday applications like high
jumping
so in general you know we you know let's
say that this is a bar
this is a side view of a bar right and
this is the thing holding the bar and a
guy wants to jump over the bar
his center of mass is you know most
people's center of mass is around their
gut i think evolutionarily that's why
our gut is there because it's close to
our center of mass so there's two ways
to jump
you could just jump straight over the
bar kind of like a hurdle jump in which
case your center of mass would have to
you know
cross over the bar and we could figure
out this mass and we could figure out
how much energy and how much force is
required to propel a mass that high
because
we know projectile motion and we know
all of newton's laws
but what you see a lot in the olympics
is people doing a very strange type of
jump
where when they're going over the bar
they look something like this
their backs are arched over the bar
that's not a good picture
but what happens when someone arches
their back over the bar like this hope
you get the point this is the bar right
here
what's interesting when when if you took
the average of this person's density and
figure out his geometric center and all
of that the center of mass in this
situation if someone jumps like that
actually travels below the bar
because the person arches their back so
much if you took to the average of the
total mass of where the person is their
center of mass actually goes below the
bar
and because of that you can clear a bar
without having your center of mass go as
high as the bar and so you need less
force to do it or another way to do it
another way to say it with the same
force you could clear a higher bar
hopefully i didn't confuse you but
that's exactly why
these high jumpers
cur arch their back so that their center
of mass is actually below the bar and
they don't have to exert as much force
anyway hopefully you found that to be a
vaguely useful introduction to the
center mass and i'll see you in the next
video on torque